ALAN ALVARADO, GIL ARCHULETA.
ASHBY ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ DALLY. DODD. DURAZO
EGGMAN. GLAZER. GONZALEZ GROVE.
HURTADO. JONES LAIRD. LIMON.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. MIN. NEWMAN
NGUYEN. NILO. OCHOA PADILLA.
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO. SOTO
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
STERN. UMBERG. WAHAB WIENER.
WILK MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. WHAT? OUR MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS. BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY. PLEASE RISE.
WELL. PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY OUR
CHAPLAIN, SISTER MICHELLE
GORMAN. AFTER WHICH WE'RE GOING
TO ASK YOU TO REMAIN STANDING
FOR THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG. LET US GATHER IN THE
PRESENCE OF OUR GOD. MERCIFUL
GOD, WE GATHER AGAIN AFTER REST
AND RELAXATION TO CONTINUE THE
ONGOING WORK OF GOVERNMENT. IN
THE WORDS OF THE POET BRENDAN
KENNELLY, LET US BEGIN AGAIN TO
THE SUMMONING BIRDS, TO THE
SIGHT OF THE LIGHT AT THE
WINDOW. BEGIN TO THE ROAR OF
MORNING TRAFFIC ALL ALONG END
STREET. EVERY BEGINNING IS A
PROMISE BORN IN LIGHT AND DYING
IN DARK. DETERMINATION AND
EXALTATION OF THE SEASONS.
FLOWERING. THE WAY TO WORK.
BEGIN TO THE PAGEANT OF QUEUING
CONSTITUENTS. THE ARROGANT
LONELINESS OF CROWS DOWNTOWN
BRIDGES LINKING THE PAST AND
FUTURE, OLD FRIENDS PASSING
THOUGH WITH US. STILL, THOUGH WE
LIVE IN A WORLD THAT DREAMS OF
ENDING THAT ALWAYS SEEMS ABOUT
TO GIVE IN. SOMETHING THAT WILL
MUST ACKNOWLEDGE. CONCLUSION.
INSISTS THAT WE FOREVER BEGIN.
AND SO MAY WE CONTINUE TO TRUST
IN THE PRESENCE AND GUIDANCE OF
OUR GOD. AMEN. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR
WHICH IT STANDS. ONE NATION
UNDER GOD, INDIVISIBLE, WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
MEMBERS WELCOME BACK. WE HAVE A
FULL AGENDA SO WE WANT TO GET
MOVING. SO WE'RE GOING TO ASK
MEMBERS TO BE PREPARED AT THEIR
DESKS. FIRST OFF, WE'RE MOVING A
PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR. FIRST UP
WE HAVE SENATOR NGUYEN. SHOWED
UP THE CARETAKERS. SO WE'LL SEE
YOU NEXT WEEK. MAY SCRAMBLE.
SENATOR NGUYEN, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
TODAY, I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A
CONTRIBUTION TO DEMOCRACY THAT
IS LONG OVERDUE. AS EVERYONE
KNOWS, THE FALL OF SAIGON AND
THE END OF THE VIETNAM WAR WERE
DECADES AGO. BUT MOST PEOPLE DO
NOT KNOW THAT A BRAVE GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS ESCAPED AND ESCAPED
TO AMERICA AND FOUNDED MEDIA
COMPANIES TO PROMOTE DEMOCRACY
AND EDUCATE US ABOUT THE ONGOING
THREAT OF COMMUNISM. THESE MEDIA
OUTLETS ARE STILL IN EXISTENCE
TODAY, 50 YEARS LATER. THEY
FLOURISHED IN LITTLE SAIGON,
WHEREAS IN MY DISTRICT IN ORANGE
COUNTY, THESE COMPANIES, IN
COMPARISON, IS WHAT WE YOU CAN
SAY THEY'RE FOX. THEY'RE CNN,
THEY'RE WASHINGTON POST, THEY'RE
NEW YORK TIMES, YOU NAME IT.
THESE ARE THE PILLAR AND THE
MEDIA OF THE VIETNAMESE
COMMUNITY WORLDWIDE. IN FACT,
THESE COMPANIES HAVE BECOME
WORLDWIDE NEWS POWERHOUSES ON
RED AND ON RED AND DOZENS OF
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD. I
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE FOUNDERS
OF THE VIETNAMESE NEWSPAPERS,
RADIO AND TV COMPANIES. AS I
SAID AGAIN, I'M SO BLESSED. EVEN
THOUGH THEY GET TO BROADCAST
ACROSS THE WORLD AND ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY, PARTICULARLY,
ESPECIALLY IN CALIFORNIA, THEIR
HOME BASE IS IN MY DISTRICT. LET
ME TELL YOU WHAT THEY'VE
ACCOMPLISHED AS HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF VIETNAMESE ESCAPE
AND IMMIGRATE TO AMERICA, IT WAS
A CHALLENGE TO COMMUNICATE WITH
ONE ANOTHER AS A COMMUNITY. I
WAS IN THAT GROUP. MY FAMILY
FLED. I CAME HERE, WAS FIVE
YEARS OLD, SPOKE ZERO ENGLISH.
MOST OF US SPOKE NO ENGLISH, AND
FEARED FOR FRIENDS AND FAMILIES
THAT WERE LEFT BEHIND AND THAT
WERE STILL IN THE REFUGEE CAMPS.
BUT WE HAD JOURNALISTS AND WE
HAD BUSINESS, ENTREPRENEURIAL
LEADERSHIPS AMONG OUR
POPULATION, AND THEY BEGAN
FORMING MEDIA COMPANIES IN OUR
NATIVE LANGUAGE. THESE FOUNDERS
LOVE OUR NEW AMERICAN HOME AND
THE DEMOCRATIC FORM OF
GOVERNMENT. THEY WERE FIERCELY
PROTECTIVE OF IT AND BEGAN
DELIVERING THE NEWS ABOUT WHAT
WAS HAPPENING IN ASIA, INCLUDING
HUMAN AND RELIGIOUS RIGHTS AND
PROSECUTION OF COMMUNISM
REGIMES. THEY ALSO AIDED
REFUGEES IN THEIR QUEST TO
ASSIMILATE IN AMERICA BY GIVING
THEM MUCH NEEDED ADVICE AND
INFORMATION TO START OVER IN
THIS GREAT COUNTRY. THEY HAVE
CONTINUED TO BE THE VOICE OF THE
VIETNAMESE COMMUNITY AND OUR
POLITICAL PROCESS HERE IN
AMERICA. LITTLE SAIGON IN MY
DISTRICT IS THE LARGEST
POPULATION OF VIETNAMESE
NATIONALS OUTSIDE VIETNAM, AND
ONE OF ITS PRIMARY SOURCES OF
NEWS HAS COME FROM THESE
INDIVIDUALS. HERE THEY ARE. THE
FOUNDERS, THE CEO, THE GENERAL
MANAGER OF ALL THE STATIONS. IF
ONE OF THEM COVER YOU, YOU'RE
COVERED ACROSS THE WAR. WE ARE.
SADLY, THOUGH, SEEING IN AN ERA
WHERE SHRINKING MEDIA NUMBER OF
MEDIA COMPANY BECAUSE OF THE
COVERING OF THE NEWS IS SO
EXPENSIVE. SO I WANT TO HONOR
AND TREASURE THESE COMPANIES.
THESE FOUNDERS AND ENTREPRENEURS
AND THANK THEM FOR BRINGING
TOGETHER THE NEWS, THE GOOD, THE
BAD AND THE UGLY TO THE
COMMUNITY SO THEY CAN UNDERSTAND
NOT WHAT'S HAPPENING JUST IN
LITTLE SAIGON OR IN VIETNAM, BUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING AROUND THE
WORLD AND WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
AMERICA, AND PARTICULARLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN CALIFORNIA TODAY. I
HAVE HERE WITH ME FROM AVA TV,
JENNY DOE. ACTUALLY, SOME OF
THESE FOLKS ARE HERE TODAY. IF
NOT, THEY I STILL WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THEM AS WELL, IBC TV
MIAMI FROM LITTLE SAIGON RADIO
AND TV. DEREK NGUYEN, CATHERINE
MC NGUYEN FROM LITTLE, FROM
LITTLE SAIGON TV, THAI AND
JOSEPH DINH FROM SAIGON RADIO
HÌNH HØI WILK THAI NGUYEN FROM
SBTN TV GRUPO NGUYEN AND NGUYEN
NGUYEN. THERE'S NO RELATIONSHIP.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE THAT CLEAR,
FROM, FROM USA TV NÂNG NGUYEN,
VNA TV LINH PHAM, MILAN PHAM, VÌ
HUONG NGUYEN VÆ NCR SON VAN
NGUYEN, VBS TV FATHER JOSEPH
NGUYEN. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
HONORING AND THANKING THESE
HEROES FOR DEDICATION AND
COMMITMENT TO HUMAN RIGHTS,
RELIGIOUS FREEDOM, DEMOCRACY,
AND BEING THE VOICE OF THE
VIETNAMESE COMMUNITY AROUND THE
WORLD. I WISH THESE COMPANIES
MORE AND MORE SUCCESS, AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR 50 YEARS OF
DEDICATION TO OUR COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE, WE SAY
WELCOME AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND AT THIS TIME, I
WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT THEM A
RESOLUTION. AND WE HAVE ONE FOR
ALL OF THEM HEADING BACK TO THE
DISTRICT OFFICE. BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO TAKE THE
PICTURES WITH THEM. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT.
IF ANY OTHER MEMBERS WOULD LIKE
TO BE IN THE PHOTO NOW IS THE
TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WELCOME.
NEXT UP WE HAVE SENATOR WILK FOR
INTRODUCTIONS. SENATOR WILK, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU. I'M HERE TO INTRODUCE
MY PERSONAL FRIENDS FROM SANTA
CLARITA VALLEY, BRIAN AND LAURA
KIRCHOFF, WHICH RIGHT UP HERE,
THEY'RE ENJOYING THE BALMY
WEATHER HERE IN SACRAMENTO
BECAUSE IT'S A WAY BETTER THAN
IT IS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY. LAURA HAS BEEN A LONG
TIME NONPROFIT SECTOR LEADER IN
THE SANTA CLARITA VALLEY, IN
FACT, VERY INVOLVED IN A VERY
SUCCESSFUL NONPROFIT THAT
CATERED TO THOSE GOING THROUGH
THE STRUGGLES OF CANCER, HER
LEADERSHIP AND HER ORGANIZATION
PERSONALLY TOUCHED THE LIVES OF
MY FAMILY, MANY OF YOU KNOW THAT
MY WIFE, VANESSA, HAS LEUKEMIA,
AND MY SON, SCOTT JUNIOR, WENT
THROUGH A BOUT OF CANCER, WHICH
HE'S NOW BEEN CLEAN FOR ALMOST
FIVE YEARS, FOR SOME OF MY
SENATE COLLEAGUES, OUR LOSS,
BECAUSE SHE'S NO LONGER THERE IS
YOUR GAIN BECAUSE SHE NOW WORKS
FOR THE NORTHRIDGE MEDICAL
CENTER IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY. WITH THEIR FOUNDATION
AND IS GOING TO DO GREAT THINGS
THERE AS WELL. SO IF YOU COULD
PLEASE GIVE THE KERKHOFFS A WARM
SENATE WELCOME, I'D APPRECIATE
IT. THANK YOU. WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. NEXT UP
WE HAVE SENATOR ARCHULETA FOR
INTRODUCTIONS. SENATOR, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS. IT'S
WITH GREAT ADMIRATION AND
HEARTFELT GRATITUDE THAT I RISE
TO INTRODUCE DEPUTY UNDER
SECRETARY OF THE UNITED STATES
ARMY, MR. MARIO DIAZ, FROM MY
HOMETOWN OF WHITTIER, MONTEBELLO
AND THE SURROUNDING AREAS THAT,
WE ALL GREW UP TOGETHER. AND HE
IS NOW THE, THE MAN WHO SUPPORTS
US IN THE UNITED STATES ARMY,
MARIO DIAZ WAS APPOINTED AS THE
21ST DEPUTY UNDER SECRETARY OF
THE UNITED STATES ARMY ON
OCTOBER 10TH, 2021, AND SERVES
AS THE PRINCIPAL CIVILIAN SENIOR
ADVISOR TO THE SECRETARY AND
UNDER SECRETARY OF THE ARMY,
WITH A DISTINGUISHED 30 YEAR
MILITARY CAREER, MR. DIAZ HELD
KEY LEADERSHIP ROLES IN HIS TIME
OF SERVICE, INCLUDING COMBAT
COMMAND IN IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN
AND STRATEGIC ASSIGNMENTS SUCH
AS THE MILITARY ASSISTANT TO THE
SECRETARY OF THE ARMY, FORMATIVE
STRATEGIC ASSIGNMENTS INCLUDED
MILITARY ASSISTANT TO THE
SECRETARY OF THE ARMY AND SENIOR
MILITARY ASSISTANT TO THE UNDER
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE FOR POLICY.
HE IS A GRADUATE OF WEST POINT
AND A NATIONAL WAR COLLEGE
GRADUATE, AND HE HOLDS A MASTERS
OF ARTS IN HISTORY AND IS
MARRIED WITH THREE ADULT
DAUGHTERS. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
GIVING HIM A WARM SENATE WELCOME
TO THE DEPUTY UNDERSECRETARY OF
THE UNITED STATES ARMY, MR.
MARIO DIAZ.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE, AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE. IF MEMBERS WANT TO JOIN
IN AND PITCHERS, NOW WOULD BE
THE TIME.
THANK YOU. AND WELCOME. NEXT UP
FOR INTRODUCTIONS, WE HAVE
SENATOR UMBERG SEN. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES.
MR. PRESIDENT, COLLEAGUES, I'D
LIKE YOU TO WELCOME THE FUTURE
LEADERS OF CALIFORNIA, THE FOLKS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE TAKING OUR
SEATS, THE FOLKS THAT ARE GOING
TO BE RUNNING THIS STATE AND
RUNNING THIS COUNTRY. AND THOSE
ARE THE YOUNG SENATORS FROM THE
34TH SENATE DISTRICT WHO ARE ALL
HERE IN SACRAMENTO TO SEE US
PERFORM. SO IF WE'D ALL SAY
HELLO TO THE 34TH SENATE
DISTRICT YOUNG SENATORS, I'D BE
GRATEFUL. AND THANK YOU, MR.
SECRETARY. EXCUSE ME, MR.
PRESIDENT, FOR RECOGNIZING THAT.
WELCOME TO THE YOUNG SENATORS
FROM THE 34TH SENATE DISTRICT.
THANK YOU. NEXT UP, WE HAVE
SENATOR SKINNER. OKAY. YOU SIT
HERE. YEAH. YOU CAN SIT HERE,
MEMBERS, I'M VERY PLEASED TO
INTRODUCE MY GUEST ON THE FLOOR.
THERE. IF YOU WANT TO TALK TO.
OKAY YOU CAN SAY HI TO EVERYBODY.
MY GUEST TODAY IS RONAN HELENE
O'ROURKE. MY GRANDDAUGHTER.
RONAN. WOULD YOU LIKE TO SAY
HELLO, SENATORS? I DON'T WANT
TO. OKAY YOU DON'T HAVE TO. YOU
DON'T HAVE TO. BUT YOU'RE HAPPY
TO BE HERE. YEAH. YOU LIKE IT,
OKAY. AND ALSO MY HUSBAND,
LANCE, HER GRAMPY IS ALSO HERE
IN THE BACK. AND RONAN WANTED TO
COME AND SEE YOU ALL BEFORE HER.
NANA GETS TERMED OUT. SO THAT'S
WHY YOU CAME TO VISIT ME AT
WORK, RIGHT? YEAH. YEAH, YEAH.
OKAY THANK YOU. WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
MEMBERS, WITHOUT OBJECTION, WILL
NOW GO TO THE SENATE THIRD
READING AND TAKE UP THE
FOLLOWING RESOLUTIONS OUT OF
ORDER TODAY. FIRST, WE'LL HAVE
FILE ITEM 46, SR 95 BY SENATOR
NEWMAN, FOLLOWED BY FILE ITEM
49, SR 102 BY SENATOR MIN. AND
FINALLY FILE ITEM 50, SCR 164 BY
SENATOR D'ARAZZO. AFTER THE
ADOPTION OF EACH RESOLUTION WILL
MOVE TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
FOR THE AUTHOR TO INTRODUCE
THEIR GUESTS. SENATOR NEWMAN,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. OH, YES.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
RESOLUTION 95 BY SENATOR NEWMAN
RELATIVE TO LITERACY. SENATOR
NEWMAN, THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE RESOLUTION 95, WHICH
RECOGNIZES LITERACY AS A
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT ESSENTIAL TO
INDIVIDUAL EMPOWERMENT, ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES AND SOCIETAL
PROGRESS. LITERACY, AS IT HAS
ALWAYS DONE, CONTINUES TO OPEN
DOORS TO HIGHER EDUCATION,
MEANINGFUL CAREERS AND CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT. ACCORDING TO THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE FOR LITERACY,
INDIVIDUALS WITH PROFICIENT
LITERACY SKILLS CAN EXPECT TO
EARN ANYWHERE FROM 30 TO 42%
MORE THAN THOSE WITH LOWER
LITERACY SKILLS. THE NATIONAL
ASSESSMENT OF ADULT LITERACY, A
NATIONALLY REPRESENTATIVE
ASSESSMENT OF ENGLISH LITERACY
AMONG AMERICAN ADULTS AGED 16
AND OLDER, SPONSORED BY THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR EDUCATION
STATISTICS, HAS FOUND THAT
HIGHER LITERACY RATES CORRELATE
WITH INCREASED ECONOMIC
PRODUCTIVITY AND REDUCED POVERTY
RATES. CONVERSELY, WHERE
LITERACY IS NOT PRESENT, IT
PERPETUATES POVERTY AND LIMITS
UPWARD MOBILITY. THE LITERACY
PROJECT FOUNDATION REPORTS THAT
THREE OUT OF FIVE PEOPLE IN
AMERICA'S PRISONS ARE UNABLE TO
READ, AND THAT ILLITERACY IS ONE
OF THE SINGLE STRONGEST
PREDICTORS OF FUTURE
INCARCERATION. HENCE THE RECENT
RISE OF THE PHRASE. THE
ILLITERACY TO PRISON PIPELINE, A
SUBSTANTIAL BODY OF RESEARCH HAS
FOUND THAT ADDRESSING LITERACY
CHALLENGES AT AN EARLY STAGE
THROUGH EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES
CAN SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES AND HELP
BREAK INTERGENERATIONAL POVERTY
CYCLES. TO THAT END,
COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS AMONG
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS,
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS, AND
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES ARE VITAL TO
DEVELOPING EFFECTIVE LITERACY
STRATEGIES THAT SERVE EVERY
COMMUNITY AND LEAVE NO
CALIFORNIAN BEHIND. SR 95 AND
THE LARGER EFFORT TO PROMOTE AND
ENABLE LITERACY ACROSS THE
BROADEST POSSIBLE SWATH, ENJOYS
BROAD SUPPORT FROM COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS, SCHOOLS,
NONPROFITS, AND FAMILIES,
ALLOCATING RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
COMPREHENSIVE LITERACY
INITIATIVES TAILORED TO DIVERSE
POPULATIONS IS CRUCIAL. THAT'S
WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR THIS
LEGISLATURE TO RECOGNIZE
LITERACY AS A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE FOR SR 95 TODAY. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE, SENATOR WILK? THANK
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I TOO
STAND IN SUPPORT OF SR 95. I
WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR FROM
ORANGE COUNTY FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. I THINK I'D BE REMISS
WITHOUT ACKNOWLEDGING THE WORK
AND THE LEADERSHIP OF OUR
SENATOR FROM FROM BURBANK ON
THESE ISSUES, PARTICULARLY AS IT
RELATES TO DYSLEXIA. WE
CALIFORNIA, BELIEVE IT OR NOT,
WAS NOT SCREENING YOUNG PEOPLE
FOR DYSLEXIA, WHICH IS ONE OF
THE LEADING CAUSES OF BEING
ILLITERATE. AND AS SHARED BY THE
SENATOR, IT IS IT'S ONE OF THE
ONE OF THE DATA POINTS THAT
DEMOGRAPHERS USE TO PROJECT
FUTURE PRISON POPULATION IS, IS
THE LITERACY RATE OF THIRD
GRADERS. SO I KNOW HE'S GOING TO
BE LEAVING HERE AT THE END OF
THE YEAR. AND I JUST WANTED I
KNOW THAT WAS A TOUGH SLOG FOR
THREE YEARS TO GET IT DONE, BUT
IT WAS THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
I'M GLAD THE GOVERNOR SIGNED OFF
ON IT AND YOU'RE GOING TO MAKE
THE DIFFERENCE IN MILLIONS OF
YOUNG PEOPLE'S LIVES. SO I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THAT. PLEASE
SUPPORT SR 95. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
HEARING SEEING NONE. SENATOR
NEWMAN, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUE'S COMMENTS AND I WILL
REAFFIRM MY ADMIRATION FOR THE
EFFORTS OF THE SENATOR FROM
BURBANK IN ALL OF HIS WORK TO
COMBAT ILLITERACY AND DYSLEXIA,
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON. FINAL ITEM 46 ALLEN Ã
ALVARADO. GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BREAKSPEARE. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLEY AYE. DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES.
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN. AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN.
AYE NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN. AYE.
NEILA. OCHOA. BOGH AYE. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. CIERTO. AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK. AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
NEILA. AYE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
ASSURING THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR FOR
THAT.
MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYES 39. NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW UNDER PRIVILEGE OF
THE FLOOR. SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE SOME OF THE FOLKS
AND ORGANIZATIONS WHO HAVE BEEN
SO INSTRUMENTAL TO BRINGING THIS
MEASURE TO THE FLOOR TODAY.
JOINING US TODAY IN THE GALLERY
IS A COALITION OF COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS, NONPROFITS,
SCHOOLS AND EDUCATION PARTNERS
WHO HAVE TRAVELED HERE TO SHOW
THEIR SUPPORT OF SR 95. THEY
INCLUDE THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
OF CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES,
FAMILIES THAT CAN OAN OAKLAND,
FAMILIES THAT CAN OAKLAND, THE
LIGHTHOUSE COMMUNITY CHARTER
SCHOOLS, THE OAKLAND UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT SCHOOL BOARD,
THE SENECA FAMILY OF AGENCIES
AND LOVE NEVER FAILS US, LET US
GIVE THEM A WARM AND GRATEFUL
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE WELCOME
TODAY. THANK YOU. AND WELCOME TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
SENATOR. OUR NEXT UP, WE HAVE
FILE ITEM 49 BY SENATOR. MEN
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
RESOLUTION 102 BY SENATOR. MEN.
AN ACT RELATIVE TO KIMCHI DAY.
SENATOR. MEN, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
AND MEMBERS. SR 102 WOULD
DESIGNATE NOVEMBER 22ND, 2024 AS
KIMCHI DAY HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
NOW AS MANY OF YOU ARE AWARE,
KIMCHI IS A CLASSIC KOREAN DISH
MADE OF FERMENTED VEGETABLES
TRADITIONALLY PREPARED THROUGH A
PROCESS CALLED GIMJANG, WHERE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS COME TOGETHER
TO PREPARE ENOUGH KIMCHI TO LAST
THROUGH THE WINTER. IN 2013, THE
UNITED NATIONS EDUCATIONAL,
SCIENTIFIC AND CULTURAL
ORGANIZATION OFFICIALLY
RECOGNIZED GIMJANG ON ITS
REPRESENTATIVE LIST OF THE
INTANGIBLE CULTURAL HERITAGE OF
HUMANITY. THIS DESIGNATION LED
TO THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
KIMCHI DAY HOLIDAY IN KOREA AND
THE CELEBRATION OF KIMCHI DAY
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES. NOW,
FOR ME, GROWING UP AND BEING
ABLE TO CELEBRATE KIMCHI DAY IS
REALLY AN EMOTIONAL MOMENT
BECAUSE GROWING UP AS A KOREAN
KID IN THIS COUNTRY, IN
CALIFORNIA, THERE WERE NO OTHER
KOREANS IN MY CLASS. AND BACK
THEN, UNLIKE WITH MY KIDS TODAY
BEING KOREAN WAS DECIDEDLY NOT
COOL, AND SO FOR ME, GROWING UP,
KIMCHI WAS KIND OF THE,
EMBODIMENT OF EVERYTHING THAT I
KIND OF WAS LED TO FEEL ASHAMED
OF ABOUT MY OWN CULTURE. IT WAS
A STINKY FOOD THAT NOBODY KNEW.
AND LIKE, EVERYONE MADE FUN OF
IT. NO ONE WANTED TO EAT IT.
GROSS. YUCK THOSE WERE ALL THE
TERMS I HEARD WHENEVER PEOPLE
SAW KIMCHI, SO TO SEE IT
CELEBRATED TODAY, TO SEE PEOPLE
ACTUALLY EAT IT IS REALLY AN
AMAZING THING. AND IT'S VERY
GOOD FOR YOU. IT'S GOT LOTS OF
PROBIOTICS AND LIKE YOUR
FAVORITE KOREAN AMERICAN
LEGISLATOR, THE ONLY KOREAN
AMERICAN LEGISLATOR. IT'S TANGY.
IT'S UNIQUE, AND IT'S MORE THAN
A LITTLE BIT SPICY. SO I ASK
THAT YOU JOIN ME AND VOTE AYE ON
SR 102. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING AND SEEING? NONE.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN I ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE SPEER I
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLI. AYE. DODD
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE EGGMAN. GLASER
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MAGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE.
OCHOA BOG AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB WIENER.
AYE WILK. AYE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. EGGMAN. AYE
WAHAB. AYE AYES 40 NOES ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES SIX. SENATOR.
MAN NOW PRIVILEGED TO THE FLOOR.
YOU HAVE INTRODUCTIONS. THANK
YOU. I JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT
TODAY WE'RE JOINED THIS
AFTERNOON IN THE GALLERY TO HELP
CELEBRATE KIMCHI DAY IN
CALIFORNIA. BY SONYA HARRIS FROM
SAGE STRATEGIES. WE COULD GIVE
SONJA A BIG ROUND OF APPLAUSE,
WELCOME HER TO THE SENATE.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE, SONJA AND SAGE
STRATEGIES ALONGSIDE VOLCANO
KIMCHI AND BLUE HOUSE KOREAN
RESTAURANT HAVE BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN WORKING TO
INCREASE THE VISIBILITY OF
KIMCHI DAY HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ALL
OF YOUR HARD WORK AND INCREDIBLE
SUPPORT. AND SO TO CELEBRATE
KIMCHI DAY, YOU EACH HAVE A JAR
OF KIMCHI ON YOUR DESKS FROM
BLUE HOUSE BARBECUE. IT'S A
KOREAN BARBECUE. JUST TO BE
CLEAR, IT'S NOT NORTH CAROLINA
STYLE OR MEMPHIS STYLE, BUT
KOREAN STYLE. WE HOPE YOU'LL
ENJOY IT. AND I JUST WANT TO
MENTION THAT THIS WEDNESDAY
EVENING, AUGUST SEVENTH AT 5
P.M, WILL BE HOLDING A GIMCHI
DAY RECEPTION WITH KOREAN FOOD
FROM BLUE HOUSE, AS WELL AS
ENTERTAINMENT, INCLUDING A
KIMCHI MAKING DEMONSTRATION AT
THE LELAND STANFORD MANSION. ALL
MEMBERS AND STAFF ARE WELCOME TO
ATTEND AND WE HOPE TO SEE YOU
THERE. THANK YOU. NOW MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM 50. SENATOR DURAZO.
ALL RIGHT. SHE'S THERE. SHE'S
READY. SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 164
BY SENATOR DURAZO, RELATIVE TO
NATIONAL HEALTH CENTER WEEK.
SENATOR DURAZO, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
A CR 164 AS THE NATIONAL HEALTH
CENTER WEEK. HEALTH CENTERS
ACROSS THE NATION PLAY A VITAL
ROLE IN PROVIDING ACCESSIBLE AND
AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE SERVICES,
ESPECIALLY TO OUR UNDERSERVED,
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. IN MY
DISTRICT, I HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COLLABORATE WITH
SEVERAL HEALTH CLINICS ON
COMMUNITY EVENTS. QUEENS CARE, A
LOCAL NONPROFIT DEDICATED TO LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS, HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN PROVIDING VISION
SCREENINGS WITH AND CONSTITUENTS
WITH FREE PRESCRIPTION GLASSES
AT THE EVENT ITSELF, INCLUDING
OUR OWN RECENT ECHO PARK EARTH
FEST. OUR OFFICE HAS ALSO
PARTNERED WITH LA CARE, BLUE
SHIELD'S COMMUNITY RESOURCE
CENTERS AND CLINICA ROMERO ON
ANNUAL BACKPACK GIVEAWAYS,
DISTRIBUTING AS MANY AS 1000
BACKPACKS, BAGPIPE BACK PACKS
WITH SCHOOL SUPPLIES TO LOCAL
FAMILIES. OUR OFFICE ALSO HOSTED
ONE OF OUR VERY FIRST
VACCINATION CLINICS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH SAINT JOHN'S
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS. I ALSO
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
RECOGNIZE THE COMMUNITY CLINIC
WORKERS THEMSELVES, WHO ARE THE
LIFEBLOOD OF THE HEALTH CENTER
MOVEMENT. WE RECOGNIZE THEM AS
ESSENTIAL WORKERS DURING THE
PANDEMIC, BUT THEY CONTINUE TO
BE ESSENTIAL TO OUR COMMUNITIES.
FROM THE JANITORS, MEDICAL
ASSISTANTS TO CASE MANAGERS, LET
US RECOGNIZE THEIR SACRIFICE AND
WISDOM THAT THEY BRING TO HEALTH
CENTERS ACROSS THE STATE. I AM
PROUD ALSO TO SEE THE GROWING
MOVEMENT OF CLINIC WORKERS
ORGANIZING IN SEIU COMMUNITY
CLINIC WORKERS UNITED TO HAVE A
VOICE ON THE JOB WITH CLINIC
WORKERS HAVING A SEAT AT THE
TABLE, HEALTH CENTERS ACROSS THE
STATE WILL UNDOUBTEDLY HAVE A
STRONGER AND BRIGHTER FUTURE.
TODAY ALSO SERVES AS A REMINDER
THAT WE NEED TO SUPPORT
INITIATIVES AND PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN LABOR AND HEALTH CENTERS.
I AM PROUD THAT TWO HEALTH
CENTERS IN MY DISTRICT, CLINICA
ROMERO AND SAINT JOHN'S, ARE A
PART OF THE STATEWIDE SEIU
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER, LABOR
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE, SHOWING US
HOW, THROUGH PARTNERSHIP, WE CAN
INVEST IN OUR WORKFORCE. JOIN ME
IN RECOGNIZING THE NATIONAL
HEALTH CENTER WEEK AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CELEBRATE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF HEALTH CENTERS,
HEALTH CARE WORKERS, AND
IMPROVING OUR HEALTH OUTCOMES.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SENATOR
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, I
RISE TODAY ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SCR 164 CELEBRATING
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS. I TO CLAIM A SAINT
JOHN'S CLINIC AS WELL AS THE
YUMA CLINIC AND THE HEALTH CARE
FOR EVERYONE CLINIC THAT SERVES
SO MANY VULNERABLE FAMILIES IN
MY DISTRICT. CLINICS IN OUR
STATE SERVE 1 IN 3 OF OUR
MEDI-CAL PATIENTS AND ARE A
CRITICAL PART OF OUR HEALTH CARE
SAFETY NET AND SYSTEM, PROVIDING
EVERYTHING FROM MOBILE
TREATMENT. I REMEMBER DURING
COVID COMING OUT INTO SOME OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
AT HOURS, WHERE COMMUNITIES
COULD BE REACHED AND SERVED TO
ALSO PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT HELP TO PREVENT ILLNESS IN
THE FIRST PLACE. THESE CLINICS
SERVE A CRUCIAL ROLE IN AREAS
LIKE MY DISTRICT, MANY OF WHICH
HAVE BEEN DESIGNATED MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED, AND I'M SO PROUD TO
WORK WITH SO MANY OF THE CLINICS
WHO WERE ONE OF THE FIRST TO SAY
THAT HEALTH CARE WORKERS
DESERVED A LIVING WAGE AND
ENSURED THAT THEY GOT THEIR $25
AN HOUR, AND ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THOSE WHO STAND WITH ME ON A
BILL THAT I HAVE, 1067, WHICH IS
HELPING TO EXPEDITE THOSE
LICENSES FOR THOSE MEDICAL
PRACTITIONERS THAT WE SO NEED IN
OUR UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. I
WANT TO THANK MY GOOD SENATOR DE
ROSSO FROM LOS ANGELES FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR ATKINS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I WANT
TO THANK THE TWO SENATORS WHO
HAVE SPOKEN AND CERTAINLY THE
ONE SPONSORING THE RESOLUTION
TODAY, I APPRECIATE SO MUCH THE
WORK OF CLINICS IN OUR
COMMUNITY. MANY OF THESE
CLINICS, IF YOU LOOK AT THEIR
HISTORY AND YOU TALK TO THEIR
CEOS AND THE ADMINISTRATION,
THESE CLINICS GREW OUT OF
COMMUNITY NEED IN VARIOUS
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES FROM SAN
YSIDRO ALL THE WAY TO THE FAR
NORTH. THESE COMMUNITIES CAME
ABOUT COMMUNITY CLINICS CAME
ABOUT BECAUSE OF THE DIRE NEED
IN COMMUNITIES, AND THAT EXISTS
EVEN TODAY. SO I KNOW THAT THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES IS
GOING TO RECOGNIZE A FEW PEOPLE
IN A MINUTE. BUT I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THOSE WHO HAVE,
STOOD IN THIS WORK FOR DECADES
AND DECADES AND CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE CRITICAL CARE BECAUSE
WE'VE DONE SO MUCH IN CALIFORNIA
TO PROVIDE HEALTH CARE TO AS
MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE. BUT
WERE IT NOT FOR THE COMMUNITY
CLINICS, WE WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
MEET THE NEED THAT WE ARE
MEETING. AND CLEARLY WE HAVE
WORK TO DO. BUT I WANT TO LEND
MY VOICE TO THE APPRECIATION TO
THE CLINIC WORKERS, TO THOSE WHO
FOUNDED THESE CLINICS AND THOSE
WHO CONTINUE TO WORK IN THEM
TODAY. IT'S RIGHT THAT WE TAKE
TIME TO ACKNOWLEDGE THEM AND I
THANK YOU, SENATOR, FOR THAT. I
URGE AND I VOTE ON SCR 164.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM, HEARING AND SEEING NONE.
SENATOR DURAZZO, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE MEMBERS. THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
APPLYING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO
FILE ITEM 50? HEARING AND SEEING.
NONE. AYES 40. NOES ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW WE'RE GOING
TO RETURN TO PRIVILEGE OF THE
FLOOR. SENATOR ROZELL, YOU HAVE
GUESTS YOU WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE? YES THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
FRANCISCO SILVA, WHO IS
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION. THEY REPRESENT 1400
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS ACROSS OUR STATE.
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CENTERS
TREAT OVER 7 MILLION PATIENTS A
YEAR, THE MAJORITY OF WHICH ARE
MEDI-CAL AND LOW INCOME. WITH
THE EXPANSION OF HEALTH FOR ALL
HEALTH CENTER'S WORK WILL ONLY
BECOME EVEN MORE CRUCIAL. MR.
SILVA IS A FIRST GENERATION
AMERICAN WHOSE PARENTS
IMMIGRATED FROM MEXICO. HE GOT
HIS BACHELOR'S AT SANTA CLARA,
J, AT SANTA CLARA, HIS JD AT
UCLA, LAW AND MBA AT USC,
MARSHALL SCHOOL. HE TOOK OVER
LEADERSHIP OF CPA CPCA AT IN THE
SPRING OF 2022. I'M PROUD TO
HAVE MR. SILVA WITH US TODAY ON
THE SENATE FLOOR TO ALSO
RECOGNIZE NATIONAL HEALTH CENTER
WEEK AND ALL THE GOOD WORK
CLINICS AND FEDERALLY QUALIFIED
HEALTH CENTERS DO FOR OUR
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES, JOIN ME
IN THANKING MR. SILVA. THANK YOU
AND WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE.
MEMBERS WHO ARE GOING TO STAY
WITH PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR AT
THIS TIME. WE'RE GOING TO
RECOGNIZE SENATOR ATKINS,
SENATOR ATKINS, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU SO MUCH. I
THINK I WANT TO SAY JOINING US
IN THE GALLERY TODAY, I WANT TO
INTRODUCE, SOME MOTHERS AND SOME
OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE FROM THE SAN
DIEGO CHAPTER OF JACK AND JILL
OF AMERICA, WHO'VE JOINED US IN
THE GALLERY TODAY. AND LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA ANA, I WANT
TO SAY THAT THESE ARE CURRENT
AND FUTURE LEADERS IN
CALIFORNIA, THE PERSON
SPONSORING THIS TODAY COULDN'T
LEAVE THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR, BUT I
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AKILAH WEBER, WHO WAS
HERE EARLIER TODAY. AND I DON'T
KNOW IF HER SONS, KADIR AND
JALEEL ARE STILL WITH HER ON THE
FLOOR OR IF THEY'VE JOINED, THE
FOLKS UP TOP. SO I WANT TO CALL
THEM OUT BECAUSE I'VE KNOWN THEM
FOR A VERY LONG TIME. JACK AND
JILL, FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT MAY
NOT BE AWARE, IS A NATIONAL
NATIONWIDE ORGANIZATION OF
MOTHERS FOCUSED ON UPLIFTING
FUTURE BLACK LEADERS THROUGH
COMMUNITY SERVICE, LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCACY, AND PHILANTHROPY, YOU
MAY NOT KNOW THIS. I WAS REALLY
INTERESTED TO LEARN THAT JACK
AND JILL OF AMERICA WAS FOUNDED
IN 1938, IN PHILADELPHIA,
PENNSYLVANIA, AND TODAY IT
BOASTS MORE THAN 240 CHAPTERS
NATIONWIDE, REPRESENTING MORE
THAN 40,000 FAMILY MEMBERS FROM
ALASKA TO FLORIDA. EACH CHAPTER
PLANS ANNUAL PROGRAMING
ACTIVITIES GUIDED UNDER A
NATIONAL THEME THROUGH SERVICE
PROJECTS, EACH JACK AND JILL OF
AMERICA CHAPTER CREATES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR CHILDREN TO
STIMULATE THEIR GROWTH,
DEVELOPMENT AND LEADERSHIP
CAPABILITIES. I AM PROUD THAT
THE SAN DIEGO CHAPTER WAS
FOUNDED IN 1955 AND REPRESENTS
MORE THAN 100 CURRENT AND FUTURE
LEADERS. THEY'VE TRAVELED FROM
SAN DIEGO TO SPEND THE DAY AT
THE CAPITOL LEARNING ABOUT OUR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND HEARING
FROM SOME OF OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICERS AND MEETING WITH
MEMBERS OF OUR SAN DIEGO
DELEGATION. I KNOW THEY'VE
ALREADY ENJOYED THEIR VISIT
TODAY, AND I KNOW THAT SOME OF
THEM WILL BE RETURNING IN FUTURE
YEARS AS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND
SENATORS. SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN
GIVING THEM A WONDERFUL, WARM
SENATE WELCOME. ON THE BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE, WE
SAY WELCOME. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY. NEXT UP FOR PURPOSES
OF INTRODUCTION IS SENATOR
PADILLA. SENATOR, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUES. GREAT TO BE BACK. IT
IS A DISTINCT HONOR AND
PLEASURE. WITH GREAT PRIDE, I
RISE TO INTRODUCE ONE OF MY
CONSTITUENTS, ABBY CARTER, WHO
IS THE CHAMPION OF AMERICAN IDOL
FOR SEASON 22 AND 2024. ABBY IS
A NATIVE OF INDIO, CALIFORNIA,
AND QUICKLY SET HERSELF APART
FROM THE OTHER CONTESTANTS THIS
YEAR WITH HER INITIAL AUDITION
OF WHAT WAS I MADE FOR BY BILLIE
EILISH. ONE JUDGE EVEN COMMENTED
EARLY ON RIGHT THEN AND THERE
THAT SHE MAY BE THE ONE TO WIN
AMERICAN IDOL. ABBY IS THE FIRST
WOMAN IN OVER FOUR YEARS AND
TRULY ONE OF AMERICA'S FINEST
VOCALISTS. JUST LAST YEAR, ABBY
GRADUATED SUMMA LAUDE WITH A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN MARRIAGE
AND FAMILY THERAPY FROM CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY, SAN
BERNARDINO. PALM DESERT CAMPUS.
ABBY AND HER MOTHER, ANDREA, WHO
IS ALSO A SINGER, HAVE PERFORMED
TOGETHER AT SEVERAL REGIONAL
COMPETITIONS IN THE PAST. SHE
SAYS HER MOTHER'S CONSTANT
SUPPORT IS WHAT HAS INSPIRED HER
LOVE FOR SINGING AND HER LOVE
FOR MUSIC. HER MUSIC, HER VOICE
AND HER STORY INSPIRED BOTH
JUDGES AND VIEWERS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, AND THE IMPERIAL VALLEY
IS VERY PROUD OF ALL OF ABBY'S
ACCOMPLISHMENTS. IF YOU WOULD
ALL PLEASE GIVE AMERICAN IDOL
CHAMPION ABBY CARTER A GREAT
STATE SENATE WELCOME. ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE,
WE SAY WELCOME AND
CONGRATULATIONS. THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE.
IF OTHER MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO
JOIN IN, NOW WOULD BE THE TIME
FOR THE PHOTO.
REGULAR ORDER OF BUSINESS.
MOVING ON. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ, REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ,
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR JULY 1ST, 2024
THROUGH JULY 3RD, 2024 WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK.
FOR AMENDMENTS, THERE ARE FOUR
AMENDMENTS AT THE DESK. THEY
WILL BE DEEMED ADOPTED. WE'RE
GOING TO ASK MEMBERS TO RETURN
TO YOUR SEATS. PLEASE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, PURSUANT TO JOURNAL
RULE 33.1, JOINT RULE 61 WILL BE
SUSPENDED TO ALLOW THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE TO REPORT AB 2496
AFTER THE DEADLINE. THIS REQUEST
HAS BEEN APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE. WITHOUT OBJECTION,
THE FOLLOWING GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEE DOCTOR HARINGA
DHINGRA, AS A MEMBER OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA,
WILL BE STRICKEN FROM THE FILE.
SENATOR WILK, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RETURN FILE ITEM 40, SB 1146 TO
THE ASSEMBLY FOR FURTHER ACTION.
AND AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR, PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM
208 AB 2807 FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. DESKS WILL NOTE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. ON
BEHALF OF THE AUTHOR, I WOULD
LIKE TO REQUEST THAT AB 3168 BE
PULLED OFF CONSENT FOR THE
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU. THE DESK WILL NOTE, SENATOR
JONES. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR,
PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM A, 43
ACR 182 BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DIXON
FROM THE INACTIVE FILE AND
PLACED BACK ON FILE AND AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR, PLEASE
REMOVE FILE ITEM 212 AB 2745 BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR FURTHER
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU. THE DESK
WILL NOTE. SENATOR ATKINS, THANK
YOU. I WOULD REQUEST THAT AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR TO REMOVE
AB 2424 FROM THE CONSENT AGENDA
FOR PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS. JUST
WILL NOTE, SENATOR LAIRD. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR, PLEASE
REMOVE FILE ITEM 211 AB 2628
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU. THE DECIMAL NOTE, SENATOR
WIENER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR, PLEASE REMOVE AB 598,
WHICH IS FILE NUMBER 25 FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. I JUST WILL
NOTE, SENATOR ALLEN. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I'VE GOT TWO
ITEMS. FIRST OF ALL, AB 2599,
WHICH IS FILE ITEM 210. WE ASK
THAT IT BE REMOVED FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR, THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR FOR THE PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENT. SECONDLY, AB 2885
FILE ITEM 213. WE ASK THAT IT BE
REMOVED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR FOR THE PURPOSES OF
CHAPTERING AMENDMENTS. THE DESK
WILL NOTE. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
FURTHER ACTIONS BY MEMBERS?
HEARING AND SEEING NONE. NOW
WE'LL MOVE TO CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE. WE HAVE SENATE
MEAN SECOND READING FILE ITEMS 1
TO 29. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 80.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2488 WITH
AMENDMENTS 27 TO 29, WITH
AMENDMENTS 25, 53, 25, 93, 27,
12, 30, 57, 24, 81, WITH
AMENDMENTS 2741, WITH AMENDMENTS
3080, WITH AMENDMENTS 2424, 1971
SECOND AND 15 SECOND READINGS.
DEMARET THANK YOU. NOW WE'RE
MOVING TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. FILE ITEM 33.
SENATOR GROVE, SHE'S PREPARED.
YOU MAY READ THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, FILE ITEM
33 IS A CONFIRMATION OR. EXCUSE
ME, RECONFIRMATION OF, OF THE
FOLLOWING APPOINTMENTS. JOSEPH
COUNTRYMAN, MARY JANE GRIEGO AND
BRIAN JOHNSON FOR THE CENTRAL
VALLEY FLOOD PROTECTION BOARD,
TOMMY RANDALL AND ROGER SALAZAR
FOR THE OFF-HIGHWAY MOTOR
VEHICLE RECREATION COMMISSION.
AND DOCTOR, MARK LÀ AND DOCTOR
ZIA ZAFIR FOR THE STATE MINING
AND GEOLOGY BOARD. THESE
INDIVIDUALS WERE APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON A FIVE ZERO
VOTE ON JUNE 26TH. RESPECTFULLY
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE APPOINTMENTS, HEARING AND
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM 33.
ALAN I ALVARADO. GILL I
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY I
DODD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE I HURTADO I
JONES I LAIRD I LIMON I MAGUIRE
I MENGIBAR I MEN I NEWMAN I WHEN
I NILO I OCHOA BOGH I PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
CIERTO I SKINNER I SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WIENER I WILK I. AYES 40 NOES
ZERO. THE APPOINTMENTS ARE
CONFIRMED NOW MEMBERS WE'RE
MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY. THIRD
READING FILE ITEM 54. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL 1770
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ. AN
ACT RELATING TO EMERGENCY
SERVICES. SENATOR DODD. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. YES, COLLEAGUES,
I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT AB 1770,
A BILL AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FREDERICK RODRIGUEZ AND
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT. THE BILL
CODIFIES A PROJECT THAT THE
SEISMIC SAFETY COMMISSION
RECENTLY APPROVED TO IDENTIFY A
IDENTIFY FIRE STATIONS
VULNERABLE TO EARTHQUAKES AND
ASSESS THE EXTENT TO WHICH
STATIONS ARE USING EARTHQUAKE
EARLY WARNING TECHNOLOGY TO HELP
KEEP THEIR CREWS SAFE. IT MAKES
SURE OUR FIRST RESPONDERS ARE IN
A POSITION TO QUICKLY RESPOND
FOLLOWING AN EARTHQUAKE, AND I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. HEARING
AND SEEING. NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. IS THIS
ELIGIBLE MEMBERS, THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON FILE
ITEM 54? HEARING AND SEEING.
NONE. AYES 40. NOES ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS,
WE'RE MOVING TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. NOW WOULD BE THE TIME
FOR ANY MEMBER WISHING TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ANY MEMBERS WISHING TO
MOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR HEARING. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY BILL
2154, 29, 48, 29, 85, 29, 87,
30, TEN. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALAN, I. ALVARADO. GILL I
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY I
DODD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE I HURTADO I
JONES I LAIRD I LIMON I MAGUIRE
I MENGIBAR I MEN I NEWMAN I
NGUYEN I NIETO I OCHOA I PADILLA
I PORTANTINO I RATH I RUBIO I
CIERTO I SKINNER I SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS I STERN I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WIENER WILK I. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS WIENER I IT'S A
VOTE OF 40 TO 0. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NEXT TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS AND FOLLOWED BY
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS FOR
ADJOURN IN MEMORY. SO ON
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS
ARE THERE COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. SENATOR CABALLERO.
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WILL IS IN RECESS AND
WILL GO BACK TO BUSINESS RIGHT
AFTER WE'RE DONE TODAY IN ROOM
2200 IN THE STREET. THANK YOU,
SENATOR CABALLERO. SENATOR
LIMÓN, THANK YOU. THE JOINT
COMMITTEE ON EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT WILL BE MEETING IN
ROOM 1100.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NEXT TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS FOR ADJOURN IN
MEMORY. I'D LIKE TO ASK MEMBERS
TO RETURN TO THEIR DESKS SO WE
CAN GIVE OUR COLLEAGUES THE
ATTENTION OF THE FLOOR. FIRST
UP, WE WANT TO RECOGNIZE SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF HAIG
PAPAZIAN, FORMER PRESIDENT AND
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
COMMERCE CASINO IN THE CITY OF
COMMERCE, RIGHT OUTSIDE LOS
ANGELES. AND HAGOPIAN WAS A
VISIONARY LEADER WHOSE
CONTRIBUTIONS WERE CRITICAL IN
THE GROWTH AND ADVANCEMENT OF
THE CARD ROOM INDUSTRY, WHICH
ALSO AFFECTS THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. HIS IMPACT AND
LEADERSHIP AT THE COMMERCE
CASINO AND HOTEL WERE
INSTRUMENTAL IN SHAPING THE
COMMERCE CASINO INTO THE
OUTSTANDING ENTERTAINMENT
DESTINATION IN TODAY. THROUGHOUT
LOS ANGELES AREA, MR. HAIG
PAPAZIAN BECAME A DIRECTOR OF
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS IN 1995,
WAS ELECTED CHAIRMAN OF THE
BOARD IN THE YEAR 2000, AND
BECAME THE PRESIDENT CEO OF THE
COMPANY IN JUNE OF 2009. DURING
HIS TENURE AS PRESIDENT AND CEO
FROM 2009 TO 20 2021, MR.
PAPAZIAN LED INITIATIVES AND
TRANSFORMED THE CARD ROOM
INDUSTRY, ENHANCE THE PLAYER
EXPERIENCE AND FOSTERED A
CULTURE OF EXCELLENCE AND
INTEGRITY IN THE INDUSTRY. A
RESPECTED LEADER IN THE
COMMUNITY, HE WAS FOREVER
CHAMPIONING VARIOUS EFFORTS TO
GIVE BACK TO THE COMMUNITY AND
THOSE IN NEED AND ENSURING THAT
THE COMMERCE, CASINO AND HOTEL
WAS A POSITIVE FORCE IN THE CITY
AND SURROUNDING AREAS IN THE
GREATER LOS ANGELES. HACOPIAN
WAS A VISIONARY AND A MENTOR AND
A FRIEND TO ME FOR YEARS, AND HE
STARTED WHEN HE STARTED, I
STARTED IN POLITICS. HE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN CREATING
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ENVIRONMENT,
WHERE HE AND THE EMPLOYEES FELT
THEY COULD BE PART OF THE
COMMUNITY. THEIR COMPANY, AND HE
SET THE EXAMPLE OF EXCELLENCE
WHEN IT COMES TO MANAGEMENT,
OWNERSHIP AND WORKING WITH
EMPLOYEES. HE CONSIDERED THE
PEOPLE WHO WORKED AT THE
COMMERCE CASINO TO BE HIS
FAMILY. UNDER HIS LEADERSHIP,
THE COMMERCE CASINO BECAME A
PLACE WHERE EVERYONE WORKED HARD
AND DEVOTED THEIR TIME TO AND
THEIR PERFORMANCE TO LEAD THE
MARKET AND FOCUS ON COMPLIANCE
AND SERVING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS WELL. HE WILL
ALWAYS BE CHERISHED AND A MEMBER
OF THE COMMERCE FAMILY. HIS
FOCUS IN FOSTERING TEAMWORK,
PROMOTING EXCELLENCE LED THE
COMPANY TO THE NAME AND ANNUAL
EMPLOYEE OF THE YEAR AWARDS IN
HONOR OF THOSE WHO WORKED AT THE
CASINO. SURROUNDING AREAS. MR.
HAGUE, THE CARD ROOM INDUSTRY
WORKED TOGETHER AS A FAMILY TO
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE AND HIS
CHILDREN. FOR THESE REASONS AND
MANY, MANY MORE, I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY AND I
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ARCHULETA ON THIS ADJOURN IN
MEMORY, WE RECOGNIZE SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND I, TOO, RISE AND
JOIN MY COLLEAGUE FROM PICO
RIVERA AND ADJOURNING AND THE
MEMORY OF MY DEAR FRIEND MR.
HAGUE PAPAYA. I KNOW THE SENATOR
SPOKE OF HIS ESTEEMED CAREER IN
THE CARD INDUSTRY, BUT THAT'S
NOT HOW I MET HAGUE. I MET HAGUE
BECAUSE HIS FAMILY WAS IN THE
TRASH BUSINESS, AND I WAS A
YOUNG RECYCLING COORDINATOR WITH
LÀ CONSERVATION CORPS, AND THEN
I BECAME THE SOLID WASTE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CITY OF COMPTON.
AND IT WAS THROUGH TRASH THAT I
GOT TO KNOW MR. RABIN. AND HE
WAS A DEDICATED INDIVIDUAL AND
IMPLEMENTING RECYCLING. AND MOST
OF THE MUNICIPALITIES THAT HE
HAD CONTRACTS WITH. HE WAS A
VISIONARY IN THIS FIELD, AND I
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY WHEN I SERVED
ON GARDENA CITY COUNCIL BECAUSE
OF MR. PEPIN'S COMMITMENT NOT
ONLY TO CITIES, MAKING SURE THEY
HAD GREAT SERVICES, WE FORMED A
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP, PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP, AND THE
ONLY REASON I LED THAT EFFORT IS
BECAUSE MR. PEPIN WAS PART OF
THAT. HE WAS COMMITTED TO MAKING
SURE THAT THE CITY HAD THE BEST
RATES, BUT ALSO WHAT SOLD ME ON
IT. HE MADE SURE TWO AFRICAN
AMERICANS WERE PART OF THAT
OWNERSHIP OF THAT COMPANY. AND
THAT'S UNHEARD OF IN THE TRASH
BUSINESS. THAT'S WHO HAGUE PEPIN
WAS. AND HE'S BEEN A DEAR FRIEND,
AND I ENJOYED OUR TIME AT
FRIENDLY HILLS. EVEN THOUGH WE
ALWAYS JOKE THERE WAS NOTHING
FRIENDLY ABOUT THOSE HILLS AT
HIS GOLF COURSE. BUT WE ALWAYS
HAD A GOOD TIME, PLAYING GOLF
AND TELLING STORIES. HE WAS
DEEPLY INVOLVED WITH CONTRACT
CITIES AND INDEPENDENT CITY
ASSOCIATION. HE SUPPORTED ALL
THOSE ORGANIZATIONS. WHEN I WAS
A LOCAL CITY COUNCIL PERSON, AND
HE CARED ABOUT THE COMMUNITY AND
MANY FOLKS KNOW, I HAVE A JAZZ
FESTIVAL THAT I STARTED 22 YEARS
AGO. HAGUE PEPIN WAS THE FIRST
SPONSOR OF THAT EVENT, AND HE
STILL SPONSORS IT TO THE DAY
THROUGH HIS WICKS COMPANY. AND
HE WAS AGAIN JUST A GOOD HUMAN
BEING. I GOT TO KNOW HIS KIDS,
GOT TO KNOW HIS WIFE, AND JUST
SHORTLY, A FEW YEARS AGO, HE
MOVED TO TEXAS TO BE CLOSER TO
HIS MEDICAL TREATMENT AT MD
ANDERSON. BUT AGAIN, HE
ESTABLISHED HIMSELF IN THAT
COMMUNITY BY OPENING A
RESTAURANT NAMED SAVOR AND
EVERYONE A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
THAT IT WAS OPEN HAD RAVE
REVIEWS, NOT ONLY ON THE FOOD,
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, ON THE
TYPE OF QUALITY SERVICE THAT IT
PROVIDED, BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
HAGUE WAS WAS ABOUT GIVING BACK.
HE WAS JUST A DOWN TO EARTH GUY
WITH NO PRETENSE ABOUT HIM, AND
GENEROUS TO A FAULT. AND HE
WOULD GIVE THE SHIRT OFF HIS
BACK TO ANY OF HIS FRIENDS OR
ANY COMMUNITY ORGANIZATION. AND
I CAN LIST ALL THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HE WAS PART OF. BUT, I
WOULD BE HERE ALL DAY, BUT HE
WAS A JUST A TREMENDOUS FRIEND
TO SO MANY, A GREAT, HUSBAND, A
AMAZING FATHER. AND I ASK THAT
WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF HAGUE
PAPAYA. THANK YOU, SENATOR
BRADFORD. AND SENATOR ARCHULETA,
THE SENATE EXTENDS ITS
CONDOLENCES TO MR. PAPAZIAN'S
FAMILY AND FRIENDS. PLEASE BRING
HIS NAME FORWARD SO HE MAY BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED IN OUR
JOURNAL. AND THAT WE MAY ADJOURN
IN HIS MEMORY. NEXT UP, WE WANT
TO RECOGNIZE SENATOR NILO. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS,
PLEASE JOIN ME IN ADJOURNING IN
MEMORY OF ALDO PECCI JUNIOR, WHO
I WAS VERY FORTUNATE TO HAVE AS
A FRIEND AND A SUPPORTER. ALDO
WAS RAISED IN A FAMILY WITH
PASSION FOR COMMUNITY, LOCAL
POLITICS AND PHILANTHROPIC
SERVICE, AND HIS UPBRINGING
TRULY INFLUENCED HIS LIFE'S
WORK. HE WAS BORN IN ROSEVILLE
ON DECEMBER 13TH, 1957, ATTENDED
SAINT ROSE CATHOLIC SCHOOL,
ROSEVILLE HIGH SCHOOL, AND
SIERRA COLLEGE, LATER
TRANSFERRING TO UC DAVIS TO
PURSUE A DEGREE IN POLITICAL
SCIENCE. THROUGHOUT HIS TIME IN
SCHOOL, HE EXCELLED BOTH
ACADEMICALLY AS WELL AS
ATHLETICS IN TRACK AND FIELD. HE
RETURNED HOME TO ROSEVILLE AFTER
GRADUATION, WHERE HE RECONNECTED
WITH LESLIE GOTTO, HIS CHILDHOOD
FRIEND AND NEIGHBOR, ON A MORE
INTIMATE BASIS. IF YOU KNOW WHAT
I MEAN. THEY WERE MARRIED IN
1986 AND LATER HAD A DAUGHTER OF
ANGELINE AND A SON, ANTHONY,
PROFESSIONALLY, ALDO PECCI.
CONSULTING QUICKLY GREW IN
REPUTATION. TRULY VALUED FOR HIS
Kò KEEN INSTINCT. VERY FEW AND
REALLY ONLY THE UNWISE WOULD RUN
FOR POLITICAL OFFICE OR PLACE A
MEASURE ON THE BALLOT WITHOUT
FIRST FINDING OUT WHAT ALDO
THOUGHT HIS UNIQUE UNDERSTANDING
OF THE FABRIC OF PLACER COUNTY
MADE HIM AN ASSET TO ANY TEAM HE
WAS PART OF DURING HIS 40 YEAR
CAREER. SOME OF ALDO'S
CONTRIBUTIONS IN THE REGION
INCLUDE HIS WORK WITH THE
ROSEVILLE, ROCKLAND AND LINCOLN
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE, THE PLACER
BUSINESS ALLIANCE, LIGHTHOUSE
CONSULTING, COUNSELING AND
FAMILY RESOURCE CENTER. VISIT
PLACER, THE HEALTH EDUCATION
COUNCIL, THE AMERICAN LEADERSHIP
FORMATION FORUM, THE PLACER
BREAST CANCER FOUNDATION, AND
MANY MORE, AND HE CREATED THE
VERY SUCCESSFUL SANTUCCI GOLF
TOURNAMENT, WHICH RAISES
SCHOLARSHIP MONEY FOR STUDENTS
WITHIN THE ROSEVILLE JOINT UNION
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT. IF THERE
WAS A SCHOLARSHIP FUND, A LOCAL
COMMUNITY GROUP OR NONPROFIT,
ALDO WAS MOST CERTAINLY A PART
OF IT. DESPITE HIS MANY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS, ALDO REALLY WAS
A VERY HUMBLE GUY WITH AN
AVERSION TO THE LIMELIGHT,
PREFERRING TO WORK BEHIND THE
SCENES, AND HE THOUGHT,
UNNOTICED, THOUGH OF COURSE HE
WAS ANYTHING BUT UNNOTICED. ALDO
WAS 66 YEARS OLD WHEN HE PASSED
AWAY ON MAY 28TH OF THIS YEAR,
AFTER A YEAR LONG BATTLE WITH
CANCER. HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE OF 38 YEARS, LESLIE, AND
THEIR CHILDREN OF ANGELINE AND
ANTHONY, AS WELL AS HIS SISTER
AND BROTHERS, ALL OF WHOM ARE
HERE WITH US TODAY IN THE
GALLERY. HE IS PRECEDED IN DEATH
BY HIS FATHER, ALDO, AND MOTHER,
CLAIRE MARIE. HE WILL BE
REMEMBERED AS A WISE LEADER, A
SELFLESS HUMANITARIAN AND A TRUE
PILLAR OF HIS COMMUNITY. HE WILL
BE GREATLY MISSED BY ME AND A
LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR NILO. THE SENATE EXTENDS
ITS CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY
AND FRIENDS OF ALDO PENNISI.
PLEASE BRING HIS NAME FORWARD SO
HE CAN BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED
IN OUR JOURNAL, AND THAT WE MAY
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY. NOW, I'D
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE SENATOR ROTH.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
SENATORS I ASK THAT YOU JOIN ME
THIS AFTERNOON IN ADJOURNING IN
MEMORY OF TOM HUNT. TOM WAS A
DEAR FRIEND OF MINE FROM MANY,
MANY YEARS AND A TIRELESS AND
DEVOTED PUBLIC SERVANT. HE WAS A
PRODUCT OF THE RIVERSIDE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS, AND WAS THE VERY IDEAL
OF WHAT A COMMUNITY LEADER
SHOULD ACTUALLY BE. HE SERVED
WITH DISTINCTION AS A MEMBER OF
THE RIVERSIDE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT BOARD OF EDUCATION FOR
OVER 15 YEARS, AND TOOK THE HELM
AS ITS PRESIDENT DURING ONE OF
THE MOST CHALLENGING TIMES FOR
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICT AND ALL OF
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN OUR
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. FRANKLY,
THE COVID 19 PANDEMIC, HIS CALM,
EXPERIENCED AND STEADY HAND
STEERED THE DISTRICT THROUGH
THIS ENORMOUS CRISIS AND INTO A
MUCH BRIGHTER FUTURE. HE WAS A
DELEGATE REPRESENTATIVE TO THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION FOR MANY YEARS, AND
WAS ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY COMMISSION ON
SCHOOL DISTRICT. ORGANIZATION.
TOM WAS A RENOWNED BUSINESSMAN
AND A TOP LEADER IN THE WORLD OF
COMMUNICATIONS AND GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS, FOUNDING AND
DIRECTING HAUNT PUBLIC
RELATIONS. THIS JUNE, I WAS
PRIVILEGED TO SIT WITH TOM AND
HELP HONOR HIM WHEN HE RECEIVED
THE 2024 DISTINGUISHED ALUMNI OF
THE YEAR AWARD BY THE GREATER
RIVERSIDE CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE
AND ITS LEADERSHIP, RIVERSIDE
PROGRAM. AND THAT WAS JUST ONE
WEEK BEFORE HIS UNTIMELY PASSING
ON JUNE 22ND. THIS WEEK, HIS
FAMILY AND FRIENDS WILL GATHER
TO CELEBRATE HIS INCREDIBLE
LIFE. AND ALTHOUGH WE ALL SAY
GOODBYE TO TOM, I KNOW HE WILL
LIVE FOREVER IN OUR HEARTS AND
IN OUR MEMORIES. CINDY AND I
SEND OUR LOVE AND OUR PRAYERS TO
TOM'S WIFE, JERRY, AND THEIR
DAUGHTERS, WHITNEY AND TAYLOR,
AND I WILL SAY THIS TOM WAS A
TRUE GENTLEMAN IN A WORLD THAT
SEEMS AT TIMES TO HAVE NO
FURTHER USE FOR GENTLEMEN, HE
WILL BE MISSED A LOT. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ROTH. THE SENATE EXTENDS
ITS CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY
AND FRIENDS OF MR. HUNT. PLEASE
BRING HIS NAME FORWARD SO WE CAN
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED IN THE
SENATE JOURNAL. AND THAT WE MAY
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY. MEMBERS,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. I'M
GOING TO RECOGNIZE SENATOR
BRADFORD AT THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S DESK. SENATOR BRADFORD,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND IT
GIVES ME A GREAT HONOR TO
INTRODUCE SOMEONE WHO REALLY
NEEDS NO INTRODUCTION. A LEGEND
OF BASKETBALL, A FIVE TIME NBA
CHAMPION WITH THE LOS ANGELES
LAKERS. NONE OTHER THAN MICHAEL
COOPER. MR. COOPER IS A NATIVE
OF PASADENA, AND HE WAS SELECTED
AS THE 60TH OVERALL PICK BY THE
LOS ANGELES LAKERS IN 1978.
COOPER BECAME AN INDISPENSABLE
PART OF THE LAKERS DURING THEIR
SHOWTIME ERA. BY THE END OF HIS
CAREER, HE HAD BEEN NAMED TO THE
NBA ALL DEFENSIVE TEAM EIGHT
TIMES, INCLUDING FIVE FIRST TEAM
SELECTIONS, AND WAS A 1987 NBA
DEFENSIVE PLAYER OF THE YEAR.
AFTER HIS EXEMPLARY PLAY IN THE
NBA, MR. COOPER TRANSITIONED TO
COACHING, FIRST AS ASSISTANT
COACH TO THE LAKERS AND 2000. HE
BECAME THE HEAD COACH OF THE LA
SPARKS AND GUIDED THAT TEAM TO
THEIR FIRST WNBA CHAMPIONSHIP IN
2001, AND WON THE CHAMPIONSHIP
AGAIN IN 2002. HE HAS COACHED AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA, THE BIG THREE
LEAGUE, CHADWICK SCHOOL, AND
CULVER CITY HIGH SCHOOL, AND IS
NOW ASSISTANT HEAD COACH AT CAL
STATE LA. THIS YEAR, MR. COOPER
WAS ELECTED TO THE NAISMITH
MEMORIAL BASKETBALL HALL OF FAME.
HE JOINS 13 MEMBERS OF THAT
CLASS THAT WILL BE ENSHRINED IN
THE NBA HALL OF FAME ON AUGUST
17TH, AND HE WILL BE JOINED BY
CHAUNCEY BILLUPS, VINCE CARTER
AND WALTER DAVIS, AMONGST
OTHERS. HE IS ALSO HAD AN
ESTEEMED CAREER ON SPORTS
ANALYST, JOINING HIS FORMER
COLLEAGUE NORM NIXON AND GIVING
NBA ANALYSIS. AFTER GAMES ON A
LOCAL TV STATION. AND HE'S JUST
ALL AROUND GUY, ALWAYS PRESENT
IN THE COMMUNITY, ALWAYS WANTING
TO DO GOOD THINGS. WE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF FLYING UP HERE THIS
MORNING, SO WITHOUT ANY GREAT
HESITATION, PLEASE WELCOME
MICHAEL COOPER TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE MEMBERS. YOU WILL
ALSO INVITE YOU TO A RECEPTION
FOR MR. COOPER AT THE CALIFORNIA
MUSEUM STARTING AT 330. THANK
YOU, SENATOR BRADFORD. MR.
COOPER, WELCOME TO THE SENATE.
I'D LIKE TO INVITE MEMBERS TO
JOIN SENATOR BRADFORD AND MR.
COOPER FOR A PHOTOGRAPH.
THANK YOU ALL. CONGRATULATIONS.
MR. COOPER, IS THAT IT?
MEMBERS IF THERE'S NO OTHER
BUSINESS BEFORE THE SENATE.
SENATOR MCGUIRE, THE DESK IS
CLEAR. THANK YOU. SO MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. THE NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
THURSDAY, AUGUST 28TH AT 9 A.M.
AND AS A GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS
FAN, IT IS AN HONOR TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE SUCH A LAKERS FAN. A
LAKERS LEGEND IN THE HOUSE TODAY.
THANK YOU, SENATOR MCGUIRE. THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
3:30 P.M, AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE.
WE WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY,
AUGUST 8TH AT 9 A.M.